hello welcome to this video on playing
Austin's and my sons I want to ever had
this against him earlier check all right
let's say that's very nice for black on
a very good day I just ridden derby six
porn for nothing and the c-4 pawned by
means of b6 and Bishop asics it's a bit
like an improved version of the of
newman's own lines segments do this and
Knight a5 next let's do this
that's to be very careful now okay and
it probably shouldn't be eating while
recording but could resist that cookie
I'm sorry yeah now he's probably
starting to worry about his porn for
real c5 is fixing that weakness it
cannot move yep and if you have to do
this you know something has gone wrong
yeah what is this bishop doing on a
three
we have a couple of ideas now Bishop d7
rook c8 Bishop a6 rook c8 I can also
play g5 in some situations if Y it is
somewhat barely coordinate it with the
night having no squares that is also
good but you know many many good ways to
play him
okay right 25 mean that's an interesting
interesting tribe okay i can go queen g7
here or for technical let's do that
technically it looks technically sound
we takes with the Queen that would be
that would be really winning for black
because he for then drops he has to move
the Queen blame probably to d1
pretty one I have Knight g4 495 that's
also pretty nice
because currency to I have a have a
question to answer do I want to try to
win a pawn down on d5 it's not clear if
I want to know is taking ages queenston
to I can also okay so Queen takes b5 he
wants to take a six
and it's a very nice position still ever
take on b5 hmm it doesn't really like
the best move though I have to worry
about Bishop takes a 5 that I don't turn
allow allowed as possibility but i can
go Queen f7 it's not bad now I can do
that Bishop c5 this Bishop d7 wins the
piece I don't think okay
should chicks you 5 mm and whenever I
can do that clocks that looks cute 495
repeal
I didn't really calculate that I have to
admit nights is 795 night a 893 shaking
it too there should be six that looks
disastrous but I haven't completely
figured it out I go a six years to go
back but it does weaken a lot yeah this
is this is a good move attending Bishop
d7 it should also be playable after
Bishop c5
maybe Bishop c5 we should be some 97 oh
I think I've been sloppy here okay
Bishop c5 I can go no I cannot cannot go
a six
what forfeits on time yeah probably
wasn't very amused about this game but
it's just really something that is
unplayable check that position is very
very tricky already for wide to not use
material have to be a quite quite
gorgeous the way it went it was was
absolutely absolutely bad so I think I'm
pretty okay with what I did up to here
yeah if he if he takes now if you take
now this is a very nice position Bishop
d7 is also good both captures are fine
this poorness is just dropping then he
cannot prevent it prevent them then I
can it that I take it second time with
Bishop e-cigs or a six and yes this is a
complete dummy yeah mighty I should have
just gone for the technical win this is
a technically winning position and I I
wanted to be a little bit fancy there
this year I saw that but I've wanted to
do something a little bit more nice i
think this is why white wins i go here
and bishops he flips i go here and later
Bishop c4 at the end his pawns will
start to drop it cause I deception such
an air monstrously bad piece I wanted
want it to be fancy and he can't take on
c5 yeah I should have just played that
you know I didn't see that one I didn't
see the Queen 86 and this is not a clear
position at all very very bad now I
should have just played that if you see
a technically winning position you
should just do it okay
27 here yeah this this wasn't working I
think 95 here can I think this this is
as correctly as winning for black yep a
disc that is exploding also something
like this is pretty pretty nice okay he
went here and now he and I think he
could have taken again on syfy via I
overlooked that he has 97 you know that
is not not entirely clear hmm even
though ok this is given by the comp yeah
it's messy it's unnecessary if you just
play a good normal move here something
but should be seven or so his position
is strategically lost yeah but he / he
overstepped the time here probably being
frustrated about the cause of the game
but it was so much just completely
unnecessary giving white any any sort of
chances them okay thanks for watching